This baby's rough.
[whistles]
Yeah, it is.
MIKE WOLFE: Look at the logo.
FRANK FRITZ: I know.
MIKE WOLFE: The first
thing we see is Aerosmith.
I mean, plain as day.
But it's not the Aerosmith logo.
Aw, look at that guy, man.
MIKE WOLFE: That
looks like the, uh--
FRANK FRITZ: Keep on trucking!
MIKE WOLFE: Yeah.
FRANK FRITZ: "Keep
on trucking" dude.
MIKE WOLFE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's got some "keep
on trucking" dude on it.
I mean, the paint is detailed,
but I'm confused by that.
So we don't know if this is a
fan's depiction, you know, of--
somebody just liked Aerosmith.
Oh, yeah, somebody
that likes the band.
Yeah.
FRANK FRITZ: Yeah
MIKE WOLFE: The van
itself is very cool.
This is an International
Harvester Metro.
They made these things from the
late '30s into the mid-'70s.
You know, so I guess it kind
of fits the time period.
MAN: This is a '64.
MIKE WOLFE: Did you put
it up on the car trailer?
MAN: Yeah, we-- my
son and I put it up
on the trailer
because it was-- it
was pretty much buried to the--
- Oh, yeah.
You can see.
- In mud.
Oh, OK.
- So this was all in the ground.
- Ground.
- Right here?
- Ground contact.
When I first saw that van, I
thought it was pretty cool.
Essentially, the
condition it is now,
it is becoming part
of the landscape.
MIKE WOLFE: Have
you learned anything
about the van since you've--
FRANK FRITZ: Since you owned it?
I heard it through someone who
heard that the original owner
of the van, Mark Lehman,
was here on the property,
and that he had a connection
with the band itself.
MIKE WOLFE: Do you know
his contact information?
MAN: No.
I don't know.
OK.
What I know about
Aerosmith is, they
did come from around this area.
Woo.
It's held pretty good.
I guess you could
try to get some DNA
off the mattress in here.
[laughter]
There's, like, two
mattresses in there.
Look at this thing, man.
MIKE WOLFE: Wow.
Look at these, like,
old Persian rugs.
FRANK FRITZ: Yeah.
MIKE WOLFE: I'm going "CSI"
on this thing too, man.
I'm thinking to myself, OK, they
made these from the late '30s
to the late '70s.
If they used this van when
they first started rocking,
it would have been
old enough where they
could acquire it pretty cheap.
Water cooler.
Budweiser can's got age to it.
- Look at that.
It says Three Dog Night.
FRANK FRITZ: Somebody
made one of those
with those little
clicker things.
MIKE WOLFE: Label maker.
So what's the other
side look like?
Is it painted on
the other side too?
- No, this is the only--
- That's it?
- --the only paint.
- Oh, wow.
Look at this side.
[laughs] Dang, man.
FRANK FRITZ: Not
much left there.
MIKE WOLFE: This
thing is roached.
But what's holding it together
is the painting on the side.
That's the money shot.
If we can somehow prove that
this is Aerosmith's first van,
condition goes out the door.
I mean, if it's real,
then this moment
is, like, picking folklore.
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, it is what
it is right now.
I mean, I tell you what.
If it is, I mean, that's major.
- That'd be a cool piece.
- You know?
Yeah.
MIKE WOLFE: What
do you want for it?
Let me ask you that.
Do you know what
you want for it?
[laughs] I guess
that's to be determined.
I'd feel terrible if I were
to offer this to somebody
and then find out later
that it was, you know--
It was the original van.
Or sell it under
false pretenses
saying that it has Aerosmith,
and them getting something
that--
MIKE WOLFE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
--is bogus.
FRANK FRITZ: Right.
I gotcha.
So you have to get
ahold of, I mean--
Pin it down.
Yeah.
--someone in the organization,
whether it be management,
someone in the band.
- Their roadie, bus driver.
- I mean, yeah.
I mean, somebody that was--
somebody that's been with them,
obviously, for a while.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
It's not like we can
just call up Steven Tyler
and go, hey, man,
what are you doing?
This is Mike and Frank.
I think I found your van.
Clic.
Well, let me think about
some-- let me, uh--
What kind of
connections do we have?
MIKE WOLFE: So Frank
and I are having
a conversation
about who we would
know to connect the dots here.
I mean, I don't
know how to help you
other than for us
to try to figure
out some sort of a connection.
I mean, I have some friends in
Nashville that are musicians.
Maybe we could call one
of those guys, like Dan.
Yeah.
MIKE WOLFE: Dan
would probably know.
Dan Auerbach is a guy I've
known for a few years.
I ride motorcycles
with him all the time.
I sold him a guitar,
sold him an amp.
So I got a pretty good
relationship with him.
You know, you ever
heard of The Black Keys?
MAN: Yeah.
MIKE WOLFE: I mean, I
know him pretty well.
I could call him and ask him if
he knows anybody in the group--
you know, in Aerosmith.
Here's the money
shot right here.
Let me get it.
FRANK FRITZ: Yeah, this is it.